ALAN ARCHULETA AT KANSAS STATE
BACKER FORGES BRADFORD
COMBINADO CORTEZ C. DALLEY DODD
DURAZO EGGMAN GLAZER GONZALEZ
GROVE HERZBERG WEST SO HER TADO
JONES CAM AUGER LAYERED LEYVA
WE MOAN WIRE MELINDA'S MEN
NEWMAN NIELSEN A CELLO BOW HAND
FORTUNE TINO ROSSI. RUBIO
SKINNER TURN ON BERG WAIT.
WINNER WELL. MEMBERS A QUORUM
IS PRESENT. WITH THE MEMBERS
AND OUR GUEST B. ON THE RAIL
AND IN THE GALLERY PLEASE RISE
WE WILL BE LED IN PRAYER THIS
MORNING BY SENATOR BRADFORD
AFTER WHICH PLEASE REMAIN
STANDING WE WILL BE LED IN THE
PLEDGE OF ALLEGIANCE TO THE
FLAG BY SENATOR DR SO. GRACIOUS
GOD OF MERCY AND COMPASSION.
THIS WEEKEND IN THE CELEBRATION
OF JUNETEENTH. WHICH
COMMEMORATES THE EMANCIPATION
OF ENSLAVED PEOPLE IN UNITED
STATES. RUN JUNE NINETEENTH
EIGHTEEN SIXTY FIVE THE PEOPLE
OF TEXAS RECEIVED INFORMATION
THAT THEY HAD BEEN PROCLAIMED
ON JANUARY ONE. EIGHTEEN SIXTY
THREE. AND WE CONGRATULATE OUR
U. S. SENATE FOUR AND CONGRESS
FOR PASSING- YESTERDAY THE
LEGISLATION MAKE THIS A
NATIONAL HOLIDAY MERCIFUL GOD
WE ASK THAT YOU CONTINUED
PRESENCE WITH US AS WE STRIVE
TO MAKE REAL THE PROMISE OF
JUSTICE AND LIBERATION OF ALL.
MAY WE LEARN TO CELEBRATE
FREEDOM FROM OPPRESSION IN FULL
HUMANITY OF EVERY PERSON ON
EARTH. WE ARE GRATEFUL FOR THE
RESILIENCE AND CONTRIBUTIONS OF
BLACK AMERICANS IN EVERY ASPECT
OF OUR SOCIETY. AND ON THIS
WEEKEND WHEN WE CELEBRATE
FREEDOM. MAY WE PLEDGE TO
ENSURE BY WORD AND DEED THAT WE
WILL NO LONGER BE COMPLICIT AND
VIOLENCE ABUSE AND
DISCRIMINATION. PERPETRATED ON
PEOPLE OF COLOR. WE CLING TO
THE HOPE THAT UNITY AND
LIBERATION FOR ALL OUR WITH
BEER OUR GRASS WE ASK THESE IN
YOUR NAME. COMMENT. COLLEAGUES
PLEASE JOIN ME IN THE PLEDGE OF
ALLEGIANCE TO THE FLAG. S. S.
HE. MESSAGES FROM THE GOVERNOR
WILL BE DEEMED TO READ MESSAGES
FROM THE ASSEMBLY WILL BE
DEEMED TO READ REPORTS A
COMMITTEE WILL BE DEEMED DREAD
AND AMENDMENTS ADOPTED. MEMBERS
I WOULD LIKE TO ACKNOWLEDGE
SENATORS SENATORS AND SENATOR
MAN'S FAMILY WHO ARE VISITING
TODAY AND OBSERVING OUR FLOOR
SESSION FROM THE GALLERY. IF
YOU COULD LET'S WELCOME HIS
WIFE JANE AND THEIR THREE
CHILDREN TEDDY KENNEDY AND
PAXTON. WE'D LIKE TO WELCOME
THEM IN FAMILY AND THANK YOU
FOR JOINING US IF YOU COULD IF
YOU COULD WAVE TO EVERYBODY I
THINK EVERYBODY WOULD LIKE TO
SEE YOU ALWAYS. THANK YOU SO
MUCH FOR JOINING US HERE TODAY
WE'RE GLAD WE'RE GLAD YOU COULD
JOIN US. RIGHT. MEMBERS ARE
GOING TO MOVE ON TO MOTIONS
RESOLUTIONS AND NOTICES SENATOR
HERTZBERG. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MR PRESIDENT. MEMBERS ARE YOU
THANK YOU MR PRESIDENT. MEMBERS
I MOVE THE ADOPTION OF AUTHORS
AMENDMENTS FOR MEASURES ACROSS
THE DESK ON FRIDAY SATURDAY AND
SUNDAY JUNE EIGHTEENTH
NINETEENTH AND TWENTIETH TWENTY
TWENTY ONE. THESE EVENTS WILL
BE ADOPTED PUBLISHED AND THE
MEASURES RETURN TO COMMITTEE.
SENATOR WELLS. AT PRESIDENT ASK
FOR A ROLL CALL VOTE. SENATOR
DODD RIGHT. WE BETTER WORK IS
ASKING FOR- CALL PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. HERTZBERG IS ASKING
FOR NINE SENATOR WELCOME. IS
ASKING FOR NOW. ALLEN ALAN. HI
ARCHULETA HI ATKINS HI BABY. NO
BACKER HI FORGES NO BRADFORD.
HI BY ADAM HI CORTESE. HI SALLY.
NO DODD. HI TORONTO HI ADNAN
FIVE GLAZER HI GONZALEZ FIVE
GROVE. NO HERTZBERG HI WITH SO.
HER TADO. JONES NO CAN LONGER I
LAYERED HI LLEVA. I LIVE ALONE
FIVE MCGUIRE HI MELINDA'S NO
MAN HI NEWMAN HI NIELSEN. A
SHOW OF BOTH. NO PAN HI FORTUNE
TINO FIVE ROTH HI RUBIO I
SKINNER. STERN HI NUMBER FIVE
BY CAL SKI. I WINNER I WILL
RIGHT NOW. HEY. FIVE TWENTY
EIGHT NOTE EIGHT THE MOTION
CARRIES. MOVING ON TO
CONSIDERATION OF THE DAILY FILE.
SECOND READING FILE PLEASE READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL. TWO SEVENTY TWO
FIVE EIGHTY THREE. NINE HUNDRED
TEN NINETY SIX ASSEMBLY BILL
EIGHT SIXTY ONE WITH AMENDMENTS
TO NINETY EIGHT WITH AMENDMENTS
AND ASSEMBLY BILL FIVE FOURTEEN
WITH AMENDMENTS THANK YOU VERY
MUCH MOVING ON THE GOVERNOR'S
APPOINTMENTS ITEM NUMBER TWELVE
SENATOR LARRY. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH MADAM PRESIDENT OF FINAL
ITEM TWELVE IS THE CONFIRMATION
OF HELEN HONG. AND I HAD A TUNE
J. HU LU DAY. TO THE FAIR
EMPLOYMENT AND HOUSING COUNCIL
BOTH IMPORTANT RESEARCH DUE TO
THE COUNCIL MISS HONG IS THE
CHIEF EXECUTIVE OFFICER CALLED.
CAL BAR AFFINITY INC MR RUDY IS
AN ATTORNEY AT THE JUDICIAL
COUNCIL OF CALIFORNIA CENTER
FOR JUDICIAL EDUCATION AND
RESEARCH THEY WERE BOTH
APPROVED BY THE SENATE RULES
COMMITTEE ON JUNE NINTH I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR I.
pOR DEBATE ON THIS ITEM. SAYING
NONE PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. ALAN
HI ARCHULETA I AT KINS I BASE.
BACKER. FIVE FOUR JUST.
BRADFORD HI BYRON HI CORTESE HI
DOLLY. GOD HI THERE ARE SO BY
ADMIN HI GLAZER. HI GONZALEZ
HIGH GROWTH. HERTZBERG HI WEST
SO. HER TADO. JONES CAM AUGER.
I LAYERED HI LLEVA I LIVE MY
OWN HI WIRE. I MELINDA'S NO MAN
HI NEWMAN FIVE NIELSEN. A SHOW
OF BOTH. PAM HI FOURTEEN TINA
HI RALPH FIVE RUBIO I SKINNER
STERN I AM BERG I LIKE HOW SKI
FIVE WINNERS I WILL. NO PLEASE
CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS. BATES
FOR JUST. DALLY NO. GROWTH NO
WITH SO. HER TADO. JONES
NIELSEN. A TRIPLE BOGEY.
SKINNER PRICE TWENTY EIGHT
KNOWS FOR THE APPOINTMENT IS
CONFIRMED BUT NOT THE ITEM
NUMBER THIRTEEN CENTER THERE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. MADAM
CHAIR FIRELIGHT I'M NUMBER
THIRTEEN IS THE CONFIRMATION OF
GABRIEL SANDOVAL TO THE FAIR
EMPLOYMENT AND HOUSING COUNCIL
MR SANDOVAL IS BEING RE
APPOINTED TO THE COUNCIL WORRY
NOW SERVES AS CHAIR HE IS A
PARTNER AT THE LAW FIRM OF
ATKINSON HANDLE CERTAIN LAWYER
ROAD AND ROME- DISAPPOINTMENT
WAS APPROVED BY THE SENATE
RULES COMMITTEE ON JUNE NINTH I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR I.
PHONE. IS THERE ANY DISCUSSION
OR DEBATE ON THIS APPOINTMENT.
SEEING NONE PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. ALAN. FIVE ARCHULETA I AT
KINS HI BABES NO BACKER. HI
PORGES NO BRADFORD I COME BY
ADAM HI COURTESY. I DALLY NO
DODD FIVE TORONTO. ADMIN HI
GLAZER HI CONSOLIDATES HIGH
GROWTH. NO HERTZBERG. FIVE WEST
SO. HER TADO. JONES. NO
CAMCORDER. I LAYERED I LABOR. I
LIVE ALONE FIVE MCGUIRE HI
MELINDA'S NO MAN FIVE NEWMAN I
NIELSEN. A TRIO OF BOTH NO PAN
I FORTUNE TINO HI RALPH HI
RUBIO HI SKINNER. STERN HI I'M
BERG ALL RIGHT I LIKE HOW SKI I
WINNER I WILL. NO PLEASE CALL
THE ABSENT MEMBERS. THEY'RE
ALSO I WITH SO. HER TADO.
NIELSEN SKINNER BUYS TWENTY
EIGHT KNOWS EIGHT DEPARTMENT IS
CONFIRMED ITEM NUMBER FOURTEEN
CENTER THERE THANK YOU VERY
MUCH AGAIN- MADAM PRESIDENT
FINELINE M. FOURTEEN IS THE
CONFIRMATION OF JULIE WOLINSKY
TO THE FAIR EMPLOYMENT AND
HOUSING COUNCIL MS ONE SKI IS A
SENIOR STAFF ATTORNEY AT THE
NATIONAL CENTER FOR LESBIAN
RIGHTS DISAPPOINTMENT WAS
APPROVED BY THE SENATE RULES
COMMITTEE ON JUNE NINTH I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR I.
THOUGHT. IS THERE ANY
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THIS
ITEM. SEEING NONE PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. ALAN HI ARCHULETA I
AT KINS I BASE NO BACKER. HI
FOR JUST NO BRADFORD. HI BY
ADAM HI I. FOR TENNESSEE I
DALLY. NO DODD HI TORONTO HI
EXAMINED EYE PLEASER. HI
CONSOLIDATES HIGH GROWTH NO
HERTZBERG. I WAS SO. HI HER
TADO. JONES NO CAN LONGER I
LAYERED I LLEVA HI THE MON. HI
MCGUIRE. I MELINDA'S NO MEN I
NEWMAN FIVE NIELSEN. A CHILL OF
BOTH. PAN. FIVE FOURTEEN TINA I
BROUGHT. HI RUBIO I SKINNER
STERN I AM BERG I WAKE OUT SKI
I WINNER I WILL NOW. PRICE
TWENTY NINE KNOWS SEVEN THE
APPOINTMENT IS CONFIRMED
MEMBERS ARE GOING TO MOVE ON TO
THE SENATE THIRD READING. FILE
ITEM NUMBER TWENTY. SENATOR
MELINDA IS. SHE IS PREPARED
PLEASE READ. SENATE CONCURRENT
RESOLUTION THIRTY SIX BY
SENATOR MELINDA'S RELATIVE TO
AROMATIC L. AMINO ACID
DECARBOXYLASE DEFICIENCY
AWARENESS. WHAT WE'RE GOING TO
GIVE WE'RE GOING TO. WELL GIVE
HER A MINUTE TO GET TO THEM
HIKE- SHOULD I HAVE YOU READ
THAT AGAIN. NO I'M JUST KIDDING.
SENATOR MELINDA IS. GOOD
MORNING ONE HAND I'M PRESIDENT
CHIANG COLLEAGUES THANK YOU SO
MUCH. S. C. R. THIRTY SIX
DESIGNATES OCTOBER TWENTY THIRD
AS- PARAMEDIC L. AMINO ACID
DECARBOXYLASE DEFICIENCY
AWARENESS DAY THANK YOU THANK
YOU. ALSO KNOWN AS ADC. ADC
DEFICIENCIES ARE RARE NEURO
TRANSMITTER DISORDER THAT CAN
LEAD TO THE MANIFESTATION OF A
BROAD SPECTRUM OF SYMPTOMS
INCLUDING DEVELOPMENTAL DELAY
AND MOVEMENT DISORDERS. MORE
SIMPLY PUT THIS DISORDER
IMPACTS HOW CELLS COMMUNICATE
WITH EACH OTHER. UNFORTUNATELY
THE LACK OF AWARENESS ABOUT ADC
ADC DEFICIENCY AMONG BOTH
PATIENTS AND PROVIDERS IS
LARGELY RESPONSIBLE FOR THE
HIGH RATES OF MISDIAGNOSIS.
CURRENTLY RESEARCH IS BEING
DEVELOPED FOR INVESTIGATIONAL
GENE THERAPIES PROVIDING HOPE
TO PATIENTS AND THEIR FAMILIES
AT ZERO THIRTY SIX AIMS TO
BRING AWARENESS TO ADC
DEFICIENCY TO BETTER INFORM
ABOUT THE DISORDER AND HELP
INCREASE EARLY DIAGNOSIS PLEASE
JOIN ME IN SUPPORTING THIS
RESOLUTION AND I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR I. ABOUT. IS THERE
ANY DEBATE DISCUSSION OR DEBATE
ON THIS RESOLUTION. ANY
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE. SEEING
NONE PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. ALAN
HI ARCHULETA I AT KINS HI BASE
I BACKER. HI FOR JUST FIVE
BRADFORD I COULD BUY A FIVE
PROTESTING. HI DALLY. FIVE DOT.
FIVE ZERO SEVEN FIVE EIGHT
SEVEN FIVE GLAZER. FIVE GUNS.
FIVE GROWTH FIVE HERZ BERG I
WAS SO. HI HER TADO JONES I CAN
LONGER I LAYERED FIVE LLEVA
FIVE THE MON. HI WIRE. HI
MELINDA'S I MEN FIVE NEWMAN I
NELSON. CONTROL OF BOTH. HI PAM
I FORTUNE TINO. HI RALPH. HI
RUBIO FIVE SKINNER. STERN HI
NUMBER I WAKE OUT SKI I WINNER
I WILL HI. PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBER. HER TADO.
NIELSEN SKINNER. HIGHS THIRTY
SEVEN NO ZERO THE MEASURE
PASSED THAT RESOLUTION IS
CONFIRMED. WE'RE GONNA MOVE ON
TO ITEM NUMBER. TWENTY FIVE-
CENTER PRESS RENDER STANDARDS
CENTER COME ON OR WILL BE
PRESENTING ON THIS. SO SENATOR
CAMARGO IS PREPARED PLEASE READ.
SENATE CONCURRENT RESOLUTION
FORTY ONE BY SENATOR BRADFORD
RELATIVE TO JUNETEENTH. MADAM
PRESIDENT AND COLLEAGUES AS
VICE CHAIR OF THE CALIFORNIA
LEGISLATIVE BLACK CAUCUS I.
RISE TO PRESENT S. C. R. FORTY
ONE. S. C. R. FORTY ONE
COMMEMORATES JUNETEENTH THE ONE
HUNDRED AND FIFTY SIXTH
ANNIVERSARY OF WHICH IS
HAPPENING THIS SATURDAY. AS WAS
MENTIONED IN THE PRAYER
JUNETEENTH MARKS THE DAY IN
EIGHTEEN SIXTY FIVE WHEN A
GROUP OF ENSLAVED PEOPLE IN
GALVESTON TEXAS FINALLY LEARNED
THAT THEY WERE FREE FROM
SLAVERY. BUT WOEFULLY THIS WAS
ALMOST TWO AND A HALF YEARS
AFTER PRESIDENT ABRAHAM LINCOLN
SIGNED THE EMANCIPATION
PROCLAMATION. AS MUCH AS
JUNETEENTH REPRESENTS FREEDOM
IT ALSO REPRESENTS HOW
EMANCIPATION WAS TRAGICALLY
DELAYED FOR ENSLAVED PEOPLE IN
THE DEEPEST REACHES OF THE
CONFEDERACY. ON JANUARY
EIGHTEEN SIXTY THREE PRESIDENT
LINCOLN ISSUED THE FINAL DRAFT
OF THE EMANCIPATION
PROCLAMATION WHICH DECLARED
THAT ALL PERSONS HELD AS
SLAVES. R. AND HENCEFORTH SHALL
BE FREE. OF COURSE LIKE MOST
LAWS THERE ARE EXEMPTIONS WHICH
THE SENATE ATTEMPTED TO CLOSE
BY PASSING THE THIRTEENTH
AMENDMENT A YEAR LATER
PROHIBITING SLAVERY AND
INVOLUNTARY SERVITUDE IN ALL
STATES. UNION AND THE
CONFEDERACY BUT THE AMENDMENTS
WERE NOT ENACTED UNTIL EIGHTEEN
SIXTY FIVE. POLITICS ECONOMICS
AND THE SOUTH. RECONSTRUCTION
THE TIME AFTER THAT FOCUSED ON
REBUILDING THE SOUTHERN ECONOMY
AND SOCIETY THROUGH THE
RATIFICATION OF THE THIRTEENTH
FOURTEENTH AND FIFTEENTH
AMENDMENTS WHICH GAVE BLACK
PEOPLE FREEDOM DUE PROCESS AND
THE RIGHT TO VOTE. BUT THOSE
GOALS WERE CONSISTENTLY
COUNTERED BY WHITE SUPREMACISTS
WHO WORKED TO WEAKEN BLACK
VOTING IN THE SOUTH. BY MEANS
OF GERRYMANDERING VIOLENCE
INTIMIDATION AND DISCRIMINATORY
PROVISIONS AROUND LITERACY. AND
THOSE ACTIONS USHERED IN JIM
CROW. THIS IS THE JOURNEY FOR
FREEDOM FOR BLACK AMERICANS I
HISTORY NOT TAUGHT IN SCHOOLS
AND NOT WELL KNOWN BY MOST
AMERICANS. EVEN MANY BLACK
FOLKS IT IS A JOURNEY FILLED
WITH DELAYS FALSE STARTS AND I-
USE. IT'S A JOURNEY THAT I KNOW
A LITTLE BIT ABOUT ONLY BECAUSE
MY GREAT GREAT GREAT
GRANDMOTHER. THE FIRST PERSON
TO HOLD ME WHEN I WAS BORN. HAD
BEEN BORN A SLAVE. AND HAD BEEN
FREED BY LINCOLN. AND SHE HAD
HER PAPERS AND HER REPUBLICAN
REGISTRATION CARD TO PROVE IT.
IT IS GREAT THAT THE U. S.
SENATE HAS PASSED A BILL TO
MAKE JUNETEENTH A NATIONAL
HOLIDAY. I HOPE THE PRESIDENT
SIGNS THAT BILL. WHAT I HOPE
MORE FOR OUR RIGHTEOUS
DISCUSSIONS AND ACTIONS BY THIS
BODY AROUND POVERTY ALLEVIATION
WEALTH BUILDING EQUITY AND
PROTECTING ALL OF OUR RIGHT TO
VOTE. TO DUE PROCESS AND TO BE
FREE. YOU KNOW A FEW WEEKS AGO
MY MOTHER WAS IN WHOLE FOODS
AND SHE WAS CHECKING OUT AT THE
CASHIERS WHO HAPPENS TO BE A
BLACK WOMAN AND ASK THIS WAS
GOING ON SHE WAS LOADING THINGS
OUT OF HER CAR SHE TURNED
AROUND AND SAW THIS WHITE MAN
AND HIS DOG. BOUNDING INTO
WHOLE FOODS WALKING DOWN THE
AISLE THE DOG WAS NOT LEASHED
THE DOG WAS NOT A SERVICE DOG.
AND THEY WERE JUST HAPPY AND
SHOPPING. AND MY MOTHER
FROWNED. AND FURROWED HER BROW
IN TURN TO THE CASHIER. TO LOOK
LIKE HAN AND THE CASHIER TURNED
TO HER SO EVENLY AND SAD. THEY
HAVE DOMINION OVER THEIR SALES.
IN OTHER WORDS SHE WAS SAYING.
WHITE PEOPLE ARE FREE AND WHEN
YOU KNOW YOU'RE FREE YOU ACT
FREE. IT IS A BIT MORE
UNFORGIVING AND COMPLICATED TO
BE BLACK. OUR FREEDOM FEELS
TENUOUS AND SITUATIONAL. AND
THAT IS FELT IN THE FIGHT SO IF
WE ARE FIGHTING AGAINST UNJUST
TREATMENT IN THE COURTS BY THE
STATE BAR WITHIN OUR PRISONS IF
WE ARE FIGHTING AGAINST UNFAIR
TREATMENT IN OUR SCHOOL SYSTEMS
AGAINST AN ADEQUATE HEALTHCARE
AGAINST UNFAIR BEHAVIORS BY
LENDING INSTITUTIONS OR HOUSING
PROVIDERS. AGAINST
DISPROPORTIONATELY ON CLEAN
WATER AIR OR LAND. IF WE ARE
FIGHTING TO STAY ALIVE TO WALK
WITH SKITTLES OR SLEEP IN OUR
BED TO BIRD WATCH OR RIDE A
BIKE. TO HAVE BIBLE STUDY IN
OUR CHURCH OR GO JOGGING OR
EVEN TO BREEZE. ALL WHILE BEING
BLACK. THEN WE ARE STILL
FIGHTING FOR THAT FREEDOM OVER
DOMINION. OVER OURSELVES. I
WOULD RESPECTFULLY ASK AT THE
RIGHT POINT FOUR AND I VOTE ON
AS THE R. FORTY ONE. THANK YOU
SENATOR KAMMERER SENATOR PYNE.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT
SENATORS- I TO RISE IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF THIS YEAR FORTY ONE
ON BEHALF OF THE ASIAN PACIFIC
ISLANDER LEGISLATIVE CAUCUS
AND- I FIND MYSELF CHALLENGE TO
FOLLOW THE ELEGANT WORDS MY
GOOD FRIEND FROM LOS ANGELES-
AND- I JUST I WOULD JUST TAKE
NOTE THAT- AND VERY SOON WE'LL
BE CELEBRATING ALSO- JULY
FOURTH. INDEPENDENCE DAY. IN
FACT ON JULY FOURTH SEVENTEEN
SEVENTY SIX OUR COUNTRY HOW WE
DECLARED OUR INDEPENDENCE- AS A
COUNTRY- IN THE DOCUMENTS WITH-
MANY ASPIRATIONS- TALKS ABOUT
THE L. WORDS OF FREEDOM- BREAKS.
BUT YET- WHEN OUR COUNTRY
ESTABLISH THIS CONSTITUTION. WE
CONTINUED TO INCLUDE BONDAGE
AND SLAVERY. FOR BLACK
AMERICANS IN FACT- AS WE ARE
TALKING ABOUT JUNETEENTH AND
THE EVENTS OF JUNE NINETEENTH
NINETEEN SIXTY FIVE THAT'S
ALMOST EIGHTY NINE YEARS LATER.
AFTER A DECLARATION OF
INDEPENDENCE WHEN FINALLY A
GROUP OF AMERICANS WERE TOLD
THAT THEY WERE NO LONGER IN
BONDAGE THAT WAS KEPT OUR
FELLOW AMERICANS IN BONDAGE.
FOR OFF FOR EIGHTY NINE YEARS.
AND SO THIS IS VERY IMPORTANT
AND RECOGNITION OF THE
STRUGGLES OF THE AFRICAN
AMERICAN COMMUNITY BLACK
AMERICANS TO JUST SIMPLY BE
FREE FROM BONDAGE NOT EQUITY
NOT EQUALITY JUST SIMPLY FREE
FROM BONDAGE AT LEAST LEGAL.
CLASS SLAVERY BONDAGE AND THEIR
STRUGGLE IS ONE THAT IS
ESSENTIAL TO OUR UNDERSTANDING
OF OUR COUNTRY AND- WHERE WE'VE
WHERE WE'VE COME FROM AND WHERE
WE NEED TO GO- CERTAINLY AS AN
ASIAN PACIFIC ISLANDER- I
APPRECIATE THE- LEADERSHIP AND
SELFLESS ADVOCACY OF SO MANY
AFRICAN AMERICANS FOR- FOR MY
COMMUNITY. FREDERICK DOUGLASS.
DR MARTIN LUTHER KING RIVER
JESSE JACKSON ARE JUST A FEW
EXAMPLES OF BLACK AMERICAN
LEADERS HAVE LENT THEIR VOICES
IN SUPPORT OF THE API COMMUNITY.
AND OUR CONTINUED SOLIDARITY
AND SUPPORT FOR ONE ANOTHER IN
THE FACE OF RACIAL INJUSTICE.
IS PART OF BENDING THAT VERY
LONG ARC- OF THE MORAL UNIVERSE
TOWARD JUSTICE. WE NEED TO BE
SURE WE MOVE FORWARD TOGETHER
AND THIS RESOLUTION IS A
REMINDER THAT THE FIGHT FOR
FREEDOM. AND THE QUALITY IS AN
ONGOING ONE AND A VERY LONG ONE
BUT ONE THAT WE MUST. I WORK
HARD TO ACHIEVE AND CERTAINLY I
WANT TO EXPRESS MY
APPRECIATION- FOR THE
LEADERSHIP OF BLACK AMERICANS
ON BEHALF OF ALL PEOPLE OF
COLOR INCLUDING THE API
COMMUNITY- IN A TRADE CHIEF
JUSTICE. SO- L. PAYING TRIBUTE
TO JUNETEENTH IS PART OF
AMERICAN HISTORY. AND IT'S A
HISTORY THAT WE SHOULD WE NEED
TO ALL LEARN. AND EMBRACE. BUT
NOT JUST KNOW THE HISTORY BUT
THEN COMMIT OURSELVES TOGETHER
AS AMERICANS. TO ACHIEVE THOSE
IDEALS ARE PROCLAIMED BY THE
FOUNDERS BACK IN SEVENTY
SEVENTY SIX. BUT HAVE NOT YET
BEEN ACHIEVED SO WITH THAT I
HEARD TONIGHT VOTE ON SCR FORTY
ONE THANK YOU. SENATOR EYES OF.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT I
RISE AS A CALIFORNIAN AS A
STATE SENATOR REPRESENTING
DISTRICT TWENTY FOUR. IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF S. C. R. FORTY ONE
RELATIVE TO JUNETEENTH.
JUNETEENTH ALSO KNOWN AS
FREEDOM THERE FOR EMANCIPATION
DAY IS SYMBOLIC IN THAT IT IS
CONSIDERED THE DATE WHEN THE
LAST SLAVES IN AMERICA WERE
QUOTE UNQUOTE FREED. ALMOST TWO
AND A HALF YEARS AFTER
PRESIDENT LINCOLN ISSUED THE
EMANCIPATION PROCLAMATION I USE
THE TERM QUOTE UNQUOTE FREED
LOOSELY. BECAUSE IT WAS IT WAS
OUTLAWED BUT WHAT ACTUALLY
OCCURRED WITH TWO VERY
DIFFERENT REALITIES. THE
ABOLITION OF SLAVERY HOWEVER
DID NOT BRING EQUALITY.
JUNETEENTH HAPPENED EIGHTY NINE
YEARS AFTER THE U. S.
INDEPENDENCE DAY AND IT WOULD
BE ANOTHER ONE HUNDRED YEARS.
BEFORE THE CIVIL RIGHTS
MOVEMENT GAIN TRACTION AND
STARTED TO RIGHT THE WRONG OF
SEGREGATION YES BLACK MEN AND
WOMEN WERE QUOTING QUOTE FREE.
BUT THEY WERE NOT FREE TO LIVE
WHERE AND HOW THEY WISHED. AS I
PREVIOUSLY SAID ON THE FLOOR
UNDERSTANDING OUR PAST. AND
KNOWLEDGE IN OUR HEROES OF OUR
DIFFERENT DIVERSE COMMUNITIES
IN CALIFORNIA. WILL STRENGTHEN
THE TIES BETWEEN EVERY RESIDENT
OF THE STATE AS WE CELEBRATE
JUNETEENTH AND ASK ALL
CALIFORNIANS TO HONOR AND
REFLECT. ON THE SIGNIFICANT
ACHIEVEMENTS AND THE IMPACT
THAT AFRICAN AMERICANS A PLATE.
IN THE EVOLUTION ON THE SUCCESS
OF THIS NATION WE MUST CONTINUE
THIS FIGHT. WITH THE GOAL OF
ENSURING REAL EQUALITY AND REAL
JUSTICE FOR OUR COMMUNITIES.
I'D IKE TO THANK THE AUTHOR IN
THE LEGISLATIVE BLACK CAUCUS
FOR YOUR LEADERSHIP EVERY
SINGLE DAY. WORK ON THIS
IMPORTANT RESOLUTION AND ASK
YOU TO SUPPORT S. C. R. FORTY
ONE THANK YOU. SENATOR MEN.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT I
ALSO RISE IN STRONG SUPPORT OF
THIS RESOLUTION- THE
LEGISLATIVE BLACK CAUCUS AND
BLACK CALIFORNIANS AND
AMERICANS JUNETEENTH IS THE
OLDEST AFRICAN AMERICAN HOLIDAY
WE HAVE SERVED THE UNITED
STATES AND IT'S IMPORTANT WE
RECOGNIZE THE HISTORY BEHIND IT.
SLAVERY IS A STAIN ON AMERICAN
HISTORY BUT THE END OF SLAVERY
THAT WE CELEBRATE. DID NOT END
SYSTEMIC RACISM IT DID NOT AND
ANTI BLACK RACISM- THESE INDOOR
TO TODAY. WE HAD FOUR HUNDRED
YEARS OF SLAVERY IN THIS
COUNTRY IT'S BEEN LESS THAN A
HUNDRED SIXTY YEARS SINCE WE
ENDED SLAVERY AND WE HAVE
PLENTY OF WORK TO DO AS WE SEE
RIGHT NOW WITH THE WAVE. OF
VOTING RESTRICTIONS THAT MANY
OF OUR COUNTERPARTS ACROSS THE
COUNTRY ARE PASSING RIGHT NOW
IN STATE LEGISLATURES. WE HAVE
A LOT OF WORK TO DO TO TRY TO
EDUCATE THE POPULATION INTO
TEAMS AND RECOGNIZING
JUNETEENTH IS A VERY VERY
IMPORTANT TO START- TECHNOLOGY
OUR COUNTRY'S MISTAKES THE
SERVICE AND EDUCATIONAL
TEACHABLE MOMENT FOR ALL OF US.
MEMBERS I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR I. BOATS. SENATOR RUBIO.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT AND
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN OF THE
SENATE TODAY I RISE ON BEHALF
OF THE LEGISLATIVE WOMEN'S
CAUCUS AND ALSO AS AN EDUCATOR
WHO STRONGLY BELIEVES IN
TELLING OUR HISTORY NO MATTER
HOW DARK IT IS SO THAT WE
EDUCATE AND NEVER FORGET AND
BECOME BETTER FOR IT BLACK
WOMEN HAVE BEEN CENTRAL TO THE
CELEBRATION OF JUNETEENTH AND
THE COMMEMORATION OF
EMANCIPATION SINCE THE
NINETEENTH CENTURY. NEARLY
EMANCIPATED SLAVES WALKED OFF
THE PLANTATION WEARING THE
FINEST CLOTHING FROM THEIR
MISTRESSES THROUGH THE UNION
CAM AND DANCING AND CELEBRATION
BEGINNING IN THE LATE
NINETEENTH CENTURY BLACK WOMEN
ACTIVISTS PUBLIC HISTORIANS OF
THE HORRORS AND HUMILIATIONS
THEY HAVE TWO INDOOR TO EDUCATE
THE NEXT GENERATION THE
ORGANIZED PAGEANTS PARADES ON
JUNETEENTH AND EMANCIPATION DAY
PORTRAYED SLAVES AND
SLAVEHOLDERS AGAIN TO ENSURE
THAT THE ATROCITIES OF THOSE
ERAS ARE NEVER FRGOTTEN.
DURING THE GREAT MIGRATION
BLACK TEXANS MOVE TO THE WEST
COAST INCLUDING CITIES LIKE LOS
ANGELES BAKERSFIELD OAKLAND AND
SACRAMENTO BRINGING JUNETEENTH
WITH THEM AFTER THE TWENTIETH
AND TWENTY FIRST CENTURY THE
LABOR OF BLACK WOMEN AS
COMMUNITY ORGANIZERS PLANNERS
ACTIVISTS FOOD PREPARERS AND
COSTUME DESIGNERS MADE
JUNETEENTH. CELEBRATIONS
POSSIBLE. JUNETEENTH IS A SALAD
OF THE FREEDOMS FOR WHICH
CATALYST BLACK WOMEN HAVE
FOUGHT. POET ABOLITIONIST
ORATOR AND SUFFRAGISTS FRANCIS
E. W. HARPER URGE WHITE
SUFFRAGISTS TO STAND UP FOR THE
BLACK SISTERS UPON HEARING THE
WORDS ALL PEOPLE ARE BORN FREE
AND EQUAL IN THE MASSACHUSETTS
CONSTITUTION ELISABET MONTH AT
FREEMAN HIRED A LAWYER AND WORK
THROUGH. THE COURT SYSTEM TO
EARN HER FREEDOM. THEY PAVE THE
WAY FOR THE BLACK WOMEN WHO
HAVE BEEN CRITICAL AND CRUCIAL
TO ADVANCING CULTURE. FEMINISM
CIVIL RIGHTS THROUGHOUT OUR
HISTORY THE WOMEN LIKE ACTIVIST
ANGELA DAVIS AUTHOR ALICE
WALKER AND OUR COUNTRY'S VICE
PRESIDENT KHAMA HARRIS HAVE ALL
BEEN UPLIFTED BY THOSE
STRUGGLES. JUNETEENTH IS A TIME
OF CELEBRATION BUT ALSO HAS A
STRONG REMINDER THAT THE FIGHT
FOR FREEDOM AND JUSTICE FOR
AFRICAN AMERICANS IS NOT OVER.
62% ARE CONFIRMED SEX
TRAFFICKING VICTIMS. WE HAVE
YET TO ACHIEVE EQUITY FOR BLACK
WOMEN IN OUR EDUCATION SYSTEM
HEALTHCARE SYSTEM AND JUSTICE
SYSTEM ONCE AGAIN WE MUST NEVER
FORGET THE DARK HISTORY SO WE
CAN ENSURE IT'S NEVER REPEATED
AGAIN AND WITH THAT I APPROACH
YOUR RIFLE THANK YOU. SENATOR
WIENER. I THANK YOU VERY MUCH
I'M PRESIDENT- I RISE AS VICE
CHAIR OF THE LEGISLATIVE JEWISH
CAUCUS- AND- INDIVIDUALLY- IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF SCR- FORTY
ONE- AND I HOPE THAT ARE UNLIKE
THE HOUSE OF REPRESENTATIVES WE
CAN MAKE THIS VOTE UNANIMOUS
TODAY IT WAS TRAGIC THAT THERE
WERE- SOME MEMBERS OF THE HOUSE
OF REPRESENTATIVES WHO CHOSE TO
VOTE AGAINST MAKING JUNETEENTH
A FEDERAL HOLIDAY- YOU KNOW
VERY SIMILAR TO THE RESISTANCE
WE THOUGHT OF MAKING MARTIN
LUTHER KING DAY. ON A FEDERAL
HOLIDAY AND I REALLY HOPE THAT
WE CAN MAKE IT UNANIMOUS TODAY
AND SO THAT WE ARE NOT GOING
DOWN- THAT- DEFENSIVE PASS BY
YOU KNOW IN THE IN THE JEWISH
TRADITION WE HAVE A CONCEPT
CALLED TIKKUN OLAM HEALING THE
WORLD- AND WHAT A KNOWLEDGE IS
THAT- EVEN THOUGH THEY MAY HAVE
BEEN ON THE SURFACE AND DID-
WHETHER IT'S INCITEMENT OF THE
JEWISH PEOPLE IN EGYPT OR THE
ENSLAVEMENT- BLACK PEOPLE IN
THIS COUNTRY. IT'S A GREAT
THING AND THOSE HORRIBLE WRONGS
ALTHOUGH WE HAVE TO ALSO LOOK
IN THE MIRROR TODAY AND SEE
WHAT LINGERS TODAY- AND HOW WE
CAN FIX THAT HOW WE CAN HEAL
THE WORLD. AND ALTHOUGH SLAVERY
ENDED- YOU'RE MORE THAN A
HUNDRED AND FIFTY YEARS AGO- WE
NOTE THAT THE VESTIGES OF
SLAVERY CONTINUE UNTIL TODAY WE
HAVE THE MODERN DAY JIM CROW OF
OUR CRIMINAL JUSTICE SYSTEM.
WHICH WE SEE THAT IT IS CLEAR
THE DAY IS LONG THE IMPACTS
THAT OUR CRIMINAL JUSTICE
SYSTEM IS HAVING ON. OUR BLACK
AND BROWN COMMUNITIES AND
PARTICULARLY ON OUR BLACK
COMMUNITIES- IN TERMS OF THE
DISPROPORTIONATE POLICING.
DISPROPORTIONATE KILLING. A
BLACK MAN IN PARTICULAR
DISPROPORTIONATE. INCARCERATION
OF BLACK PEOPLE.
DISPROPORTIONATE IMPACT IN
TERMS OF HOMELESSNESS.
RESULTING IN PART FROM THE
CRIMINAL JUSTICE SYSTEM THAT IS
A STAIN ON OUR SOCIETY THAT
LINGERS A HUNDRED MORE THAN A
HUNDRED FIFTY YEARS LATER AND
WE HAVE NOT DONE WHAT WE NEED
TO DO. DEFECTS ARE AND TO END A
TERRIBLE INJUSTICE. WE CONTINUE
TO SEE AND WE SEE IT AROUND THE
COUNTRY TODAY. ACTIVE MOVEMENTS
IN STATE LEGISLATURES AROUND
THIS COUNTRY. TO TRY TO PREVENT
BLACK PEOPLE AND OTHER PEOPLE
OF COLOR FROM VOTING. TO MAKE
IT HARDER AND WE NEED TO CALL
IT OUT FOR WHAT IT IS TO MAKE
IT HARDER FOR BLACK PEOPLE AND
PEOPLE OF COLOR. TO VOTE WHEN
WE SAW THE CHALLENGES THE LAST
ELECTION. THE CHALLENGES IN A
STATE LIKE PENNSYLVANIA OR IN
MICHIGAN OR GEORGIA OR WHATEVER
ELSE. THEY WEREN'T CHALLENGING
THE VOTING RESULTS IN THE WHITE
SUBURBAN COMMUNITIES. THEY
SPECIFICALLY WERE CHALLENGING
THE VOTES. IN AREAS IN CITIES
WITH HIGH BLACK POPULATIONS.
WHEN YOU HAD THE PENNSYLVANIA
STATE REPRESENTATIVES WHO WERE
CLAIMING THAT THEY WANTED TO
OVERTURN THAT PENNSYLVANIA
RESULTS WELL THAT THAT'S THERE
YOU WOULD THINK WITHOUT YOUR
OWN ELECTIONS YOU WERE ELECTED.
BY THE VOTERS OF PENNSYLVANIA
BUT THEY WEREN'T TALKING ABOUT
THEIR VOTERS THEY WERE TALKING
ABOUT PHILADELPHIA OR
PITTSBURGH AREAS WHERE A LOT OF
BLACK PEOPLE WERE VOTING. SO WE
NEED TO CALL THIS OUT FOR WHAT
IT IS IT'S DESPICABLE AND IT IS
STILL HERE TODAY SO LET'S
CELEBRATE JUNETEENTH. THE END
OF SLAVERY. WAS JUST AN AMAZING
STEP FOR THIS COUNTRY. BUT WE
NEED TO BE LOOKING IN THE
MIRROR ABOUT WHAT'S HAPPENING
IN THIS COUNTRY TODAY. CALL IT
OUT AND PUT AN END TO IT THANK
YOU. SENATOR CASEY. THANK YOU
MR PRESIDENT I RISE TODAY IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF SCR FORTY ONE
IN HONOR OF JUNETEENTH WHAT'S
YOUR ROLE SERVING ON THE COUNTY
BOARD OF SUPERVISORS WE TOOK A
HISTORIC STEP TOWARD
INCLUSIVITY BY BECOMING THE
FIRST COUNTY IN THE STATE TO
MAKE JUNETEENTH OUR NATION'S
OLDEST COMMEMORATION OF THE
ENDING OF SLAVERY A PAID
HOLIDAY FOR THE COUNTY OF SANTA
CLARA. THIS PROPOSAL CAME AFTER
CONVERSATIONS WITH THE
COMMUNITY REGARDING RACE
EQUITY. AND SYSTEMIC CHANGE.
DURING THE DEMONSTRATIONS OF
ALL THE DOUBT OF GEORGE FORD.
NOW WITH CONGRESS THE FOLLOWING
LEAD OF MANY COUNTIES AND
STATES ACROSS THE COUNTRY IN
PASSING THE BILL THIS WEEK. AS
WE ALL KNOW WILL WE WILL SOON
HAVE JUNETEENTH AS A FEDERAL
PUBLIC HOLIDAY ACROSS OUR
NATION PERHAPS. BUT WITH THE
SIGNATURE BY THE PRESIDENT AS
EARLY AS TODAY. WHILE SLAVERY
WAS ENDED. THE SOCIAL ECONOMIC
RACIAL INEQUALITY STILL
PERMEATE OUR COMMUNITIES WE'VE
HEARD THAT. FROM SO MANY TODAY
AND I WANT TO THANK. THE
AUTHORS ALL OF THE AUTHORS OF
PARTICULAR COLLEAGUE. FROM LOS
ANGELES. HE HAD DONE I WANT
COLLEAGUES AND MY COLLEAGUE
FROM GARDENIA- AND ALSO- WANT
TO ASSOCIATE MY COMMENTS WITH
MY COLLEAGUE FROM SACRAMENTO.
WHO INDICATED I THOUGHT-
CLEARLY- ONE OF THE- FOR
PROBLEM IS THAT SO MANY OF US
HAVE HAD. AS WE JOYFULLY SHOWED
UP FOR JUNETEENTH CELEBRATIONS
IN OUR OWN DISTRICTS UP AND
DOWN THE STATE AND ITS PEOPLE
DID THAT ACROSS THE COUNTRY.
KNOWING KNOWING. THAT WE WERE
CELEBRATING JUNETEENTH BUT
WITHOUT THE FULL FAITH AND
CREDIT OF THE UNITED STATES OF
AMERICA. OUR OWN STATE OUR OWN
CITIES AND COUNTIES ARE IN
POPULATION. THAT WE WOULD GIVE
OF JULY. TO CELEBRATE THE
LIBERATION OF THE THIRTEEN
COLONIES IN THE REST OF THIS
COUNTRY BUT THAT HAPPENED
EARLIER IT IS ALWAYS STRUCK ME
TO BE A SLAP IN THE FACE.
PARTICULARLY TO THE BLACK
COMMUNITY. IN THIS COUNTRY THAN
IN MY OWN DISTRICT. BUT TO SAY
WE WILL CELEBRATE JUNETEENTH.
BUT YOU DON'T GET THE SAME
RESPECT ON THAT DAY THAT THE
REST OF AMERICANS. CELEBRATE ON
JULY FOURTH AND- I ALSO WANT TO
INDICATE- THAT WERE NOT DONE
THIS IS A GREAT STEP TOWARD
TRUE EQUITY IN REPRESENTATION
AND I DO THINK IT INDICATES.
FARM PROBABLY AS STRONGLY AS
ANYTHING AS INDICATED IN MY
TWENTY EIGHT YEARS OF PUBLIC
SERVICE THAT THINGS CAN CHANGE
THINGS CAN CHANGE- BUT A LOT
MORE HAS TO CHANGE. MY GOOD
FRIEND. WHO GREW UP IN MY
NEIGHBORHOOD TO ME THE N.
DOUBLE ACP ROBIN JEFF MORE
PACKED UP HIS BELONGINGS. TWO
DAYS AGO. N. AS FAMILY AND
DROVE ACROSS COUNTRY TO LEAVE
HIS HOME TOWN TO MOVE TO
ATLANTA. INDICATING THAT HIS
HOME TOWN WAS NO LONGER WELCOME
ME TO THE BLACK COMMUNITY. BUT
THAT'S SOMETHING I TAKE VRY
SERIOUSLY AND THOUGH THIS IS A
HUGE STEP IN THE RIGHT
DIRECTION. TRUE I COULD BE
OBVIOUSLY- IS STILL- SOMETHING
THAT WE HAVE TO REACH FOR THANK
YOU AND I URGE EVERYONE SUPPORT
FOR A C. R. FORTY ONE. THANK
YOU MEMBERS OF. SENATOR
BRADFORD. THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT AND I WANNA THANK MY
COLLEAGUE FROM ALLY OF FOR HER
ELOQUENT WORDS AS CHAIR OF THE
LEGISLATIVE BLACK CAUCUS I WANT
TO THANK ALL OF MY COLLEAGUES
WHO HAVE. RAISE YOUR VOICE
TODAY TO SPEAK TO THIS
IMPORTANT. HISTORICAL MEASURE A
HOLIDAY THAT MANY OF YOU HERE I
HAD NEVER HEARD OF BEFORE
COMING TO THE LEGISLATURE- I
HAVE BEEN KNOWN TO MANY OF MY
COLLEAGUES. YEAR AFTER YEAR
AFTER HAVING A JUNETEENTH
CELEBRATION HERE IN THE
LEGISLATURE SAYS THIS IS THE
FIRST I'VE EVER HEARD OF IT I
DIDN'T KNOW ABOUT IT UNTIL THE
END TELL ME MORE. AND IT ONLY
LENDS ITSELF TO THE CONTINUED
MISEDUCATION. OF NOT ONLY THE
NEGRO BUT AMERICA ITSELF THE
CONTINUING WHITEWASHING AND
CONTINUED LIES A WHAT AMERICA
REALLY IS IN WHO AMERICA REALLY
IS. JUNE THIRTEENTH IS
IMPORTANT TO MY FAMILY BECAUSE
MY ENTIRE FAMILY IS FROM TEXAS
I GREW UP WITH A FATHER WHO IS
ADAMANT ABOUT CELEBRATING JUNE
EIGHTEENTH. THE LAST TEN
FIFTEEN YEARS OF HIS LIFE HE
WENT BACK TO TEXAS EVERY YEAR
IN JUNE AND SPENT THE ENTIRE
MONTH OF JUNE AND TEXAS
CELEBRATING. ANY INSTILLED IN
EACH AND EVERYONE OF US THE
IMPORTANCE OF JUNE EIGHTEENTH
NOT FOR THE JULY BUT JUNETEENTH.
AND IF YOU KNOW YOUR HISTORY
THERE ARE THREE THINGS
ASSOCIATED WITH JUNETEENTH.
WATERMELON RED SODA POP IN RED
VELVET CAKE. AND THEIR RACIAL
STEREOTYPES AFTER AMERICANS
LIKE WATER NO MORE NO WE DON'T
THE SIGNIFICANCE OF IT WAS
BECAUSE OF JUNETEENTH. AND THE
RED REPRESENTED THE BLOOD THAT
WE SHE ADDED FOR THIS COUNTRY
AS SLAVES AS PEOPLE IN THE
MILITARY AND IT SIGNIFIES THE
BLOOD THAT WE LOST AND THAT'S
WHY IT WAS RED SODA OP THAT'S
WHY WITH WATERMELON AND THAT'S
WHY WITH RED VELVET CAKE. THE
RECOGNIZE THE BLOOD THAT WE
SHED. IT TOOK ALMOST TWO
HUNDRED FIFTY YEARS OF BONDAGE.
STARTING IN NINETEEN I MEAN
SIXTEEN NINETEEN FOR AMERICA TO
FINALLY ABOLISHED SLAVERY. IT
WAS A HUNDRED FIFTY SIX YEARS
LATER THAT WE HAVE BEEN
CELEBRATING JUNETEENTH AS THE
ENDING OF SLAVERY. AND AS WE
CELEBRATE NOT ONLY. IN TEXAS
BUT IT WAS ALSO IN LOUISIANA
THEY GOT THE WORD LATE TOO AS
THEY MIGRATED WEST TO DO TO
BRING THE MESSAGE BUT THE
BONDAGE IN REMNANTS OF SLAVERY
STILL EXISTS TODAY IN THIS
COUNTRY AND AS MY COLLEAGUE
FROM SAN FRANCISCO SO
ELOQUENTLY STATED. ALL THOSE
THINGS THAT WE SUFFER FROM THE
MOST THE HEALTH DISPARITIES THE
EDUCATION THE LACK OF
EDUCATION. THE HOMELESSNESS.
THAT MASS INCARCERATION THE
CALL CENTER ON RACE WE SHOULD
ASK OURSELVES IF WE'RE REALLY
CONCERNED ABOUT SOLVING THE
HOMELESSNESS ISSUE WE SHOULD
ASK THE QUESTION HOW CAN 13% OF
THE POPULATION REPRESENT 50% OF
HOMELESSNESS THE RACE IS NOT AT
THE CORE OF EVERYTHING THAT WE
DO IN THIS COUNTRY. HOW CAN THE
GREATEST HEALTH DISPARITIES.
IMPACT PEOPLE OF COLOR IT
RAISES NOT THE PART OF
EVERYTHING THAT WE DO SO WE'RE
REALLY ABOUT CHANGING THIS
COUNTRY WE NEED TO HAVE A REAL
CONVERSATION ABOUT RACE AND I'M
HONORED THAT. R. U. S. CONGRESS
VOTED YESTERDAY AND THAT OUR
PRESIDENT SHOULD PUT A
SIGNATURE TODAY. ARE
RECOGNIZING JUNETEENTH AS A
NATIONAL HOLIDAY IT'S REALLY A
STORK BEAT FOR THIS COUNTRY BUT
AGAIN I HOPE IT'S JUST NOT. N.
WORDS ONLY IT HAS TO BE AN
ACTION IN THE WORDS OF DR
MARTIN LUTHER KING WILL
REMEMBER NOT THE WORDS OF OUR
ENEMIES BUT THE SILENCE OF OUR
FRIENDS IT'S TOO MANY OF OUR
FRIENDS SILENT ON THE REAL
ISSUES OF IMPORTANCE HERE IN
THIS COUNTRY. HERE IN THE STATE-
AND AGAIN DESPITE. WHAT WE'RE
DOING ACROSS- MEANS CELEBRATING
JUNETEENTH AS STATED. WE HAVE
STATES ALL ACROSS THIS NATION.
WHO WANT TO DENY THE
CONVERSATION. OF SLAVERY. AND
RACISM IN THIS COUNTRY WE WANT
TO REMOVE IT FROM OUR SCHOOLS.
THAT'S THE PLACE WHERE WE
SHOULD BE ENCOURAGING IT THE
MOST THE EDUCATE THE NEXT
GENERATION SO THEY KNOW THE
TRUE. STORY OF AMERICAN HISTORY.
THIS YEAR ON JUNE EIGHTEENTH
WILL REFLECT THE TENACITY AND
RESOLVE THAT IS PRESENT IN THE
CHARACTER OF ALL AFRICAN
AMERICANS. THE WAY WE WILL
OVERCOME GREAT OBSTACLES IN
THIS DARK PATH WE ARE STILL IN
THE PURSUIT OF TRUE FREEDOM.
FREEDOM TO BE OUR TRUE SELVES
OUR MOST AUTHENTIC BLACK SELVES
WITHOUT BEING THREATENED. AND
BEING UNAPOLOGETIC FOR WHO WE
ARE I STAND HERE ON APOLOGETIC
AS A BLACK MAN IN THIS COUNTRY
AND I SEE YOU BEFORE I VOTE. ON
S. C. FORTY ONE RECOGNIZING
JUNETEENTH NOT ONLY AS A STATE
HOLIDAY BUT HOPEFULLY I MEAN AS
A NATIONAL HOLIDAY. BY THE END
OF THE DAY THANK YOU. SEEING NO
FURTHER DISCUSSION OR DEBATE.
SENATOR CAMOGIE MAY CONCLUDE
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT AND
THANK YOU ALL COLLEAGUES FOR
YOUR WORDS AND YOUR EARNEST IN
SIGHT AND YOUR SUPPORT FOR THIS
RESOLUTION. YOU KNOW WE ARE
FIGHTING TO ENSURE THAT BLACK
PEOPLE LIVE JOYOUS
UNINTERRUPTED AND UNAPOLOGETIC
LIVES WITHOUT HAVING TO
APPEASE. ACCOMMODATE OR
APOLOGIZE FOR WHO WE ARE. AND
WITHOUT HAVING TO EXPLAIN WHY
IT IS OKAY THAT WE TOO CAN BE
FREE. ULTIMATELY THAT IS WHAT
ALL OF US DESIRE. AND DESERVE.
SO ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
LEGISLATIVE BLACK CAUCUS AND
THE AUTHOR OF THIS BILL ARE
CHAIR. AND IN RECOGNITION OF
THE FACT THAT THE PRESIDENT
ACTUALLY JUST SIGNED THIS BILL
A FEW MINUTES AGO. I ASK FOR
YOUR EYES ON THIS MEASURE. I
HOPE YOU WILL FIND A LOCAL
EVENT TO ATTEND THIS WEEKEND
AND THAT YOU WILL JOIN ME IN
PROCLAIMING JUNE NINETEENTH AS
JUNETEENTH ALSO KNOWN AS
NATIONAL FREEDOM DAY FOR
EMANCIPATION DAY I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR IPHONE. THANK YOU
FOR THAT UPDATE ON. THE BELL
I'M WE'RE ALL ABSOLUTELY
THRILLED WITH IT AND- MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALAN HI ARCHULETA HI AT KINS I
BASE I BACKER. HI FORGES HI
BRADFORD I COME BY ADAM HI
COURTESY I DALLY. FIVE DOT. HI
DURAZO HI ADNAN HI BLAZER FIVE
TEN DOLLARS FIVE GROVE HI HERZ
BERG. HI WEST SO. HI HER TADO.
JONES I CAN LONGER I LAYERED HI
LLEVA FIVE MENON I REQUIRE HI
MELINDA'S FIVE MEN I NEWMAN HI
NIELSEN. BY A SHOW OF BOTH HI
PAM I FORTUNE TINO I BROUGHT I
RUBIO. I SKINNER. STERN HI
AMBERG HI WHAT KIND OF SKI I
WINNER. I WILL HI. FIVE THIRTY
EIGHT NO ZERO THE RESOLUTION IS
ADOPTED- AND I THINK WE CAN
GIVE A ROUND OF APPLAUSE NOT
ONLY FOR THIS BUT ALSO FOR A
NEW FEDERAL HOLIDAY. VERY WELL
DONE MEMBERS WERE GONNA MOVE ON
RIGHT NOW. TWO ASSEMBLY THIRD
READING. WE'RE GONNA MOVE ON TO
ITEM FILE ITEM NUMBER THIRTY
FIVE SENATOR DO YOU MIND. SHE
IS PREPARED PLEASE READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL ONE OH FOUR BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER LORENA GONZALEZ
AN ACT RELATING TO PEOPLE
INSTRUCTION AND DECLARING THE
URGENCY THERE OF TO TAKE EFFECT
IMMEDIATELY. THE FLOOR IS YOUR
SENATOR THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT ASSEMBLY BILL ONE OH
FOUR BY ASSEMBLYWOMAN GONZALEZ
WOULD PROVIDE STUDENTS AND
FAMILIES WITH THE LEARNING
RECOVERY OPPORTUNITIES THEY
NEED TO OVERCOME THE CHALLENGES
CREATED BY COVERT NINETEEN.
SINCE THE ONSET OF THE PANDEMIC
STUDENTS AND FAMILIES HAVE
FACED A SCHOOL YEAR UNLIKE ANY
OTHER WE QUICKLY SAW THAT ARE
MOST VULNERABLE STUDENTS AND
FAMILIES LACKS THE NECESSARY
ACADEMIC AND TECHNOLOGY
SUPPORTS NEEDED TO SUCCEED. IN
THIS PAST FALL WE LEARNED THAT
MANY STUDENTS WERE PERFORMING
BELOW GRADE LEVEL EXPECTATIONS
WITHOUT THOSE SUPPORTS.
COUNTLESS STUDENTS HAVE
COMPLETELY DISENGAGED FROM
SCHOOL STUDENTS IN OUR MOST
VULNERABLE COMMUNITIES ALSO
FACE COMPOUNDED SOCIAL
DISPARITIES. AS THERE ARE MUCH
MORE LIKELY TO CONTRACT THE
VIRUS FACE HOUSING INSECURITY
LACK HEALTH CARE AND FACE FOOD
INSECURITY. EIGHTY ONE OH FOUR
WOULD EMPOWER STUDENTS AND
THEIR FAMILIES WITH A VARIETY
OF CHOICES THAT HOLD STUDENTS
HARMLESS INCLUDING. THE ABILITY
TO PETITION FOR GRADE RETENTION
PURSUE CREDIT RECOVERY
OPPORTUNITIES BEYOND FOURTH
YEAR HIGH SCHOOL AND REQUEST A
PASS NO PASS OPTION FOR GRADES
ATTAINED. A TEAM DID THIS
ACADEMIC YEAR. EIGHTY ONE OH
FOUR WILL ENSURE STUDENTS AND
THEIR FAMILIES CAN ADDRESS
LEARNING LOSS IN A WAY THAT.
CATERS TO THEIR UNIQUE
CIRCUMSTANCES AND- PASSING THIS
BILL NOW IS CREATE CRUCIAL TO
ENSURE SCHOOLS CAN PROCEED WITH
THE PLANNING FOR THESE OPTIONS.
BUT STATE AND FEDERAL
GOVERNMENTS ARE PROVIDING
SIGNIFICANT FINANCIAL SUPPORT
TO SCHOOLS RIGHT NOW BUT THE
COST TO SCHOOLS FROM THIS BILL
WILL BE MINOR COMPARED TO THE
VALUE THAT. THE SUPPORT THAT.
WE WILL PROVIDE TO STUDENTS
HAVE ON HAVE. WHO HAVE
STRUGGLED. THIS PAST YEAR THIS
BILL HAS RECEIVED UNANIMOUS BY
IT'S IMPORTANT RESPECTFULLY FOR
AND I. MEMBERS IS THERE ANY
DISCUSSION DEBATE ON THIS ITEM.
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE SEEING
NONE THIS BILL IS ELIGIBLE FOR
UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL IS THERE
ANY OPPOSITION TO UNANIMOUS
ROLL CALL SAYING NONE I THIRTY
SEVEN NO ZERO ON THE URGENCY
OUR EYES THIRTY SEVEN NO ZERO
ON THE BILL. MEASURE PASSES.
MEMBERS WE'RE GOING TO MOVE ON
TO THE CONSENT CALENDAR- MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE READ. GIVE ME
MADAM PRESIDENT WOULD ANYBODY
LIKE AN ITEM PULLED FROM THE
CONSENT CALENDAR. ANY ITEM
PULLED FROM THIS SITE CONSENT
CALENDAR. SEEING NONE MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE READ- CENTERED
OUT I'M SORRY I MISSED YOU I
WAS GOING TO DO THIS- UNDER
MOTIONS AND RESOLUTIONS BUT I
THINK THIS FITS- UNDER MY- AT
THE REQUEST THE AUTHOR PLEASE
REMOVE AB NINE TWENTY BOTTLE
ITEM NUMBER FIFTY SEVEN FROM
CONSENT. AND PLACED ON THE
INACTIVE FILE. I DIDN'T FILE
ITEM NUMBER FIFTY SEVEN VERY
GOOD THAT WILL BE ORDERED.
ANYONE ELSE. MADAM SECRETARY
PLEASE READ. SENATE JOINT
RESOLUTION FIVE ASSEMBLY BILL.
761-340-1370. EIGHT EIGHT
NINETY ONE FIFTEEN EIGHTY
ASSEMBLY BILL EIGHT FORTY ONE
THREE THIRTY SEVEN OF
1-383-333-6460 FOUR FIFTEEN
EIGHTY ONE AND ASSEMBLY BILL
FIFTEEN NINETY TWO. MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
ON AND NUMBER FORTY SIX. ALAN
HI ARCHULETA HI ATKINS I BASE
HI BECKER. HI FORGES BY
BRADFORD I COME BY ADAM HI
PROTESTING. HI DALLY FIVE DOT.
HI THERE ALSO HI ADNAN I GLAZER
HI CONSOLIDATES HIGH GROWTH. BY
HERTZ BERG I WENT SO. HI HER
TADO JONES I CAN LONGER I
LAYERED HI LLEVA. I LIVE MY OWN
I REQUIRE. HI MELINDA'S. MAN HI
NEWMAN HI NIELSEN BY A SHOW OF
BOTH. HI PAM I FORTUNE TINO HI
RALPH HI RUBIO HI SKINNER.
STERN HI AMBERG ALL RIGHT I
LIKE CASKEY HI WINNER I WILL.
HI HI. HIGHS THIRTY SEVEN NO
ZERO ON THE ITEM ID NUMBER ICE
THIRTY SEVEN NO ZERO ON THE
CONSENT CALENDAR MEMBERS WERE
GOING TO MOVE ON TO COMMITTEE
ANNOUNCEMENTS. COMMITTEE
ANNOUNCEMENTS US SENATOR
BURGESS. THE AG COMMITTEE WILL
MEET ENOUGH FORTY TWENTY THREE
IN FIVE MINUTES. THE
AGRICULTURE COMMITTEE WILL MEET
IN FOUR ROOM FORTY TWO OH THREE
FIVE MINUTES AFTER THE END OF
SESSION. AFTER WE CONCLUDE THAT
SENATOR MCGUIRE THANK YOU SO
MUCH BETTER PRESIDENT-
GOVERNANCE AND FINANCE
COMMITTEE WILL MEET TWENTY
MINUTES AFTER THE GERMAN- SIN
AND CULTURE. SEVEN IT'S IN-FINANCE WILL MEET IN ROOM FORTY
TWO- THREE TWENTY MINUTES AFTER
THE ADJOURNMENT OF AGRICULTURE
VERY GOOD SENATOR WIENER. I
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT- THE
HOUSING COMMITTEE WILL CONVENE
IN THE SENATE CHAMBERS AT TEN
THIRTY. VERY GOOD SENATE
HOUSING WILL MEET IN THE
CHAMBERS AT TEN THIRTY THANK
YOU SO MUCH FOR THOSE-
COMMITTEE ANNOUNCEMENT. MEMBERS
WERE GONNA MOVE. READ WE'RE
GOING TO RETURN TO MOTIONS AND
RESOLUTIONS I'D LIKE TO ASK
THAT IF YOU COULD ALL PLEASE
SIT DOWN WE'RE GOING TO THIS IS
THE TIME FOR THE INTERNET
MEMORIES AND WE WANT TO PAY.
DUE RESPECT FOR HIM FOR THOSE
THAT ARE GOING TO BE DOING AN
ADJOURN IN MEMORY. SENATOR WEST
SO. THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT
SENATORS I RISE TO ADJOURN IN
MEMORY BUT DETECTIVE RYAN PARK
AND DETECTIVE JAMIE HUNTLEY
PARK A YOUNG MARRIED COUPLE
DEDICATED TO PUBLIC SERVICE.
THE SAN DIEGO COMMUNITY AND
FRANKLY ALL OF CALIFORNIA IS
DEEPLY SADDENED BY THE TRAGIC
DEATHS OF THESE TWO COMMITTED
PUBLIC SERVANTS. DETECTIVES
RYAN PARKIN JAMIE HUNTLEY PARK
WERE INSEPARABLE. FROM THE
START OF THE RELATIONSHIP AS
POLICE RECRUITS UNTIL THE
TRAGIC END WHEN THEY WERE
KILLED IN A WRONG WAY FREEWAY
CRASH. ON TUESDAY THEY WERE
BURIED TOGETHER IN THE SAME
CASKET. ON TUESDAY. THE POLICE
CHIEF DAVID NASH LET RICARD
RECALLED. IF THEY WEREN'T
TOGETHER THEY WERE TALKING
ABOUT EACH OTHER. THE COUPLE
MET AT THE POLICE ACADEMY IN
TWENTY TWELVE AND MARRIED IN
TWENTY SIXTEEN THEY WERE
PROMOTED TO DETECTIVES ON THE
SAME DAY IN TWENTY EIGHTEEN
PARK INVESTIGATED HOMICIDES AND
HUNTLEY PARK WORKED IN THE
POLICE DEPARTMENTS OTHER
DIVISION NEAR THE BORDER WITH
MEXICO. THE DEATHS OF PARK IN
HUNTLEY PARK TWO POLICE
OFFICERS THIRTY DEDICATED TO
COMMUNITY SERVICE AND PUBLIC
SERVICE. DEVASTATED ALL WHO
KNEW THEM. FROM THEIR FAMILY
MEMBERS AND THE MEN AND WOMEN
OF THE POLICE DEPARTMENT. AND
TO THEIR NEIGHBORS IN SAN DIEGO.
DETECTIVE RYAN PARKER THIRTY TO
IS SURVIVED BY HIS MOTHER ELENA
HIS BROTHER JUSTIN AND FATHER
RICHARD DETECTIVE JAMIE HUNTLEY
PARK THIRTY THREE IS SURVIVED
BY HER PARENTS EDWARD AND SURE
REESE. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
CENTERS FOR ALLOWING ME TO.
MEMORIALIZE THEIR LIVES TODAY.
PLEASE BRING THEIR NAMES
FORWARD TO THAT SO THAT THEY
MAY BE APPROPRIATELY
MEMORIALIZED BY THE SENATE.
SENATOR COM AUGER. THANK YOU
MADAM PRESIDENT TODAY I RISE TO
A GERMAN THE MEMORY OF BUFORD
RICE SONNY WALKER WHO PASSED
AWAY ON SATURDAY JUNE FIFTH
TWENTY TWENTY ONE HE WAS EIGHTY
TWO YEARS OLD. SONNY WAS A
RESIDENT OF THE THIRTIETH
SENATE DISTRICT HE WAS BORN IN
NINETEEN THIRTY NINE. ON THE
SOUTH SIDE OF CHICAGO ILLINOIS
AND RAISED IN KANSAS CITY
MISSOURI. SONNY WAS THE FIRST
OF FOUR CHILDREN BORN TO RICE
WALKER AND VERNELL CRAWFORD
WALKER. SONNY ATTENDED CORPUS
CHRISTI ELEMENTARY AND CHICAGO
BEFORE THE FAMILY MOVED TO
KANSAS CITY MISSOURI WHERE HE
GRADUATED FROM BISHOP HOGAN
HIGH SCHOOL. A LIFELONG
CATHOLIC HE WAS CONFIRMED IN
NINETEEN FORTY SEVEN AT CORPUS
CHRISTI CATHOLIC CHURCH AND
DURING HIS YOUTH HE SERVED AS
AN ALTAR BOY. SONNY WAS AWARDED
FULL SCHOLARSHIP TO ST AMBROSE
COLLEGE IN DAVENPORT IOWA.
SUNNY KEPT AN AUDIENCE
SPELLBOUND WITH STORIES OF HIS
STREET LIGHT BASKETBALL GAMES
IN THE ALLEYS OF THE SOUTH SIDE
OF CHICAGO HE ADVOCATED FOR
BLACK ATHLETES ON KANSAS CITY
COURTS FOUGHT BACK CULTURAL AND
RACIAL ISOLATION IN IOWA
BURKE'S GOT DRAFTED TO THE
KANSAS CITY BOWLS THE PRECURSOR
TO THE CHICAGO BULLS. HE LOVES
TRAVELING TO NEW PLACES AND
RETURNING TO OLD LANDMARKS
SUNNY RETIRED AS DIRECTOR OF
GOVERNMENT RELATIONS AT
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA CALIFORNIA
WATER REPLENISHMENT DISTRICT IN
TWENTY OH FOUR. SPEAKER WILLIE
BROWN APPOINTED SONNY TO SERVE
ON THE CALIFORNIA STATE
LEGISLATURE ADVISORY BOARD ON
ALCOHOL RELATED PROBLEMS FROM.
NINETEEN EIGHTY TWO TO NINETEEN
NINETY THREE. SONY IS SURVIVED
BY JACQUELYN DUPONT WALKER HIS
WIFE OF FORTY THREE YEARS SEVEN
CHILDREN TWENTY FOUR
GRANDCHILDREN AND TWELVE GREAT
GRANDCHILDREN. PLEASE JOIN ME
AND ADJOURNING IN THE MEMORY OF
BUFORD SONNY WALKER THANK YOU.
PLEASE BRING HIS NAME FORWARD
SO HE MAY BE APPROPRIATELY
MEMORIALIZED. SENATOR LAYERED.
SENATOR LAYERED THE FLOORS
YOURS THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT
OF MEMBERS IT'S WITH GREAT
SADNESS THAT I RISE TO ADJOURN
IN MEMORY OF MIKE COURT DO YOU
KNOW WHO'S DEVOTED PUBLIC
SERVANT AND PILLAR OF THE
COMMUNITY. ARE WE ALL HERE NO
MIKE'S BROTHER CARL GUARDINO-
BUT MIKE WAS AN AMAZING
COMMUNITY MEMBER IN HIS OWN
RIGHT. A MIKE AND HIS WIFE
PATTY HAVE BEEN LONG TIME
COMMUNITY MEMBERS IN CARMEL
WHERE MY TAUGHT CHEMISTRY
PHYSICS AND BIOLOGY AT CARMEL
HIGH SCHOOL FOR TWENTY FOUR
YEARS. MIKE ALSO VOLUNTEERED
AND WORKED AT THE MONTEREY BAY
AQUARIUM FOR NEARLY TWO DECADES
TEACHING SCIENCE TEACHERS
DURING THE SUMMER. IN ADDITION
MIKE TAUGHT DIVING OFF THE
CALIFORNIA COAST TO THOUSANDS
OF PEOPLE OVER THE LAST TWENTY
YEARS. MIKE'S UNEXPECTED
PASSING ON SUNDAY MAY TWENTY
THIRD. IS MOURNED BY FAMILY AND
FRIENDS THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA
AND HE LEAVES BEHIND HIS WIFE
OF THIRTY FOUR YEARS PATTI
WONG. AND HIS CHILDREN NANCY
CHRIS AND DAVID SO PLEASE JOIN
ME IN A GERMAN TODAY IN A
MEMORY OF A VALUED TEACHER
COMMUNITY MEMBER AND FAMILY
MAN. MICHAEL R. DINO. THANK YOU
SO MUCH PLEASE BRING HIS NAME
FORWARD SO THAT HE MAY BE
APPROPRIATELY MEMORIALIZED BY
THE SENATE. MEMBERS IF THERE IS
NO OTHER BUSINESS. CENTER
SECONDS A DISK IS CLEAR. MADAM
PRESIDENT THANK YOU SO MUCH
COLLEAGUES THANK YOU A BUSY
WEEK- I HOPE YOU HAVE A
WONDERFUL WEEKEND AT HOME WITH
FAMILY OUR NEXT FLOOR SESSION
IS SCHEDULED FOR MONDAY JUNE
TWENTY FIRST TWENTY TWENTY ONE
AT TWO PM THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT. MEMBERS OF THE
SENATE WILL BE IN RECESS UNTIL
THREE THIRTY AT WHICH TIME THE
ADJOURNMENT MOTION WILL BE
PLACED. WE WILL RECONVENE
MONDAY AT TWO PM HAVE A GOOD
WEEKEND EVERYBODY.